fin de rassemblement pour la laïcité
place de la république à paris une
marche organisée à l'occasion du 220e
anniversaire de la première république
et qui intervient trois jours après
laffaire mariam pougetoux la
vice-présidente du syndicat étudiant
unef qui s'est rendu à l'assemblée
nationale vêtue d'un hidjab une
situation à l'origine d'un tollé
politique on écoute l'un des
organisateurs de l'événement genre
kuzmanovic présidents de républiques
souveraines et évidemment la laïcité ne
s'oppose pas à une réunion particulière
la laïcité d'ailleurs garantit la
liberté de culte
c'est inscrit dans la loi de 1905 en
rappelant que la religion n'est qu'une
opinion par meadow donc calé dénonçables
critiquable qu'on peut la blasphémer
c'est aussi en ce moment le procès de
charlie hebdo des attentats de charlie
hebdo mais aussi la laïcité rappellent
eux
la religion n'a rien à faire dans
l'espace public c'est quelque chose qui
est privé et lors de du groupe familial
groupe d'amis et que dans dans l'espace
public c'est la ccc les questions
exclusivement politiques qui s'expriment
autre réaction de militants cet après
midi au micro de neige abderrazak on a
l'impression en ce moment que la
république la laïcité toutes ses valeurs
ses choses qui nous fonde font de plus
en plus menacé et donc c'était important
pour moi et pour tous les gens ici à mon
avis devenir veut manifester pour
défendre ce plan met l'accent sur un
danger que je considère comme mortel
pour notre société
c'est le séparatisme quelques histoires
particulièrement le séparatisme
islamique en l'occurrence aujourd'hui
cette société laïque est attaqué de
toutes parts
les religions en particulier et donc je
suis là pour défendre cette laïcité qui
permet derrière toutes les libertés
liberté pour les femmes liberté
d'association liberté de choisir